le temps m'est venu de redevenir soleil
chante le groupe tout menkai de
redevenir l'une r o Jaguar oiseau chant
original de la famille de martignano qui
reste en goulot musicien poète
professeur et premier président de
l'Académie de la langue maya de l'état
de quintanaro et
activer
sa vie avec de beaux succès
l'enseignement
Omaya de la langue et l'écriture maya
dans les écoles des autres indigènes et
la création de l'université
interculturelle Maya à rosé Maria
Morelos des succès comme toujours dans
le monde maya arraché à force de
résistance et de lutte contre le racisme
et la marginalisation
il y a 33 langues Maya en Amérique
centrale hors du Guatemala la plus
parlée par un million de personnes et
celle de la péninsule du Yucatan le Maya
Tana el y est menacé
le soulèvement sympathiste des Mayas du
Chapas de 1994 avec parmi ces dirigeants
le mystérieux sous commandeur force le
gouvernement mexicain quelques années
plus tard à reconnaître l'autonomie des
peuples indigènes et la reconnaissance
dans la constitution du statut de langue
officielle de ces peuples au même titre
que l'espagnol avec l'obligation de
protéger d'enseigner et de promouvoir
leur culture
berline l'actuel présidente de
l'Académie Maya jusqu'à la visite en
2002 du président Vicente
il a fallu se battre encore des mois
pour créer l'Institut des langues
indigènes et aussi nommer son directeur
et encore plus longtemps pour obtenir
l'université Maya mais les Mayas sont
tenaces nous sommes ici au sanctuaire
historique de la croix qui parle donc
Cornelio poke Ménès a le titre de
général du sanctuaire par excellence il
est le gardien de la mémoire de la
Résistance Maya pendant la guerre des
castes qui a duré 50 ans jusqu'en 1901
[Musique]
résistance contre l'esclavage imposé par
les grands planteurs de sisal la fibre
qui a fait la fortune des grandes
familles créoles de Yucatan une guerre
cruelle qui a fait 250 000 morts mais
les Mayas se sont jamais rendus personne
n'a gagné
ils n'ont pas perdu sinon
nous n'existe pas que shivot village
perdu dans la forêt yukatech était
complètement isolé il y a encore 20 ans
il y a maintenant une école toute neuve
à cause de la covid les enfants sont
moins nombreux et se relaient toutes les
heures les trois premières années tout
se fait en Maya
après les plus grands alternes le Maya
et l'espagnol
l'école primaire de trappity est plus
grande à partir de la troisième année la
classe devient bilingue
autrefois les enfants autochtones
devaient apprendre à lire et écrire
d'abord en espagnol énorme handicap pour
ses enfants qui parlaient un mauvais
espagnol assimilation assurée et mort
lente du Maya depuis une vingtaine
d'années tout a changé
avec l'alphabet le plus dur est fait
apprendre l'espagnol devient facile on
voit des enfants épanouis et à l'aise
dans les deux langues le bilinguisme
devient un atout supplémentaire
cet enfant a du mal à apprendre le Maya
à cause de la pandémie ses parents ont
quitté la zone touristique de Toulouse
où il travaillait et sont revenus au
village
ou espagnol
c'est le dernier jour de la fête des
morts qui chez les Mayas durent tout le
mois de novembre tradition millénaire
autour d'un hôtel pour rendre hommage
aux disparu
chaque femme du village apporte une
spécialité qu'elle décrit à l'assistant
la cérémonie se termine par un riche et
joyeux festin
les enfants qui maîtrisent leur langue
basée sur les traditions et les contes
et légendes ne les oublieront jamais à
condition que leurs instituteurs parlent
le Maya ce qui n'est pas toujours le cas
même dans ce village modèle
[Musique]
il faut aussi que les enfants puissent
se retrouver dans le passé glorieux des
anciens Mayas
le joyau du monde de l'enseignement Maya
c'est l'université interculturelle de
rosé Maria Morelos projet obtenu de
haute lutte par les militants mayens
universitario l'os primaire axe à
l'éducation supérieure
l'université enseigne la santé
communautaire le tourisme alternatif la
gestion municipale celle d'entreprise et
la technologie de l'information et de la
communication les étudiants doivent
obligatoirement réaliser un projet
communautaire dans leur village
d'origine
l'enseignement est en Maya espagnol et
anglais ajoute Wilder name qui est aussi
poète et musicien
mais tous ces gains semblent avoir
atteint des limites l'enseignement Maya
reste confiné aux régions indigènes
auprès scolaires et aux primaires pas
aux secondaires et interdit de ces jours
dans les zones urbaines les instituteurs
issus de l'école normale Maya de
Philippe cariocuato ne peuvent pas
enseignant Maya dans les villes ordre de
leur
syndicats-unis
scolaires avec des profs de Maya comme
il y a des profs d'anglais il y a tout
un programme pour que les gens qui ne
sont pas le régime Maya les métisses
comme moi par exemple apprendre la
langue maya et ça fait un sentiment de
communauté et ça c'est très important
[Musique]
la zone touristique de quintanaro la
vache à laide du Mexique pour les
touristes tout ici et Maya les symboles
l'architecture les noms les attractions
touristiques appropriation culturelle
parfaite sans contrepartie
en 2020 le président Lopez Obrador a
demandé pardon Omaya pour l'exploitation
l'oppression et les cruauté des
Espagnols et des Mexicains au fil des
siècles belles paroles mais peu d'action
autrefois enthousiaste aujourd'hui
martignano pionnier la renaissance du
Maya et découragé
il dit que les institutions minent
intentionnellement les acquis des
Maliens
ses enfants musiciens attribuent son
pessimisme handicap subit après un AVC
mais il faut reconnaître que ne peut
compter que sur des gens comme eux et
non pas sur les institutions actuelles
pour garder en ville la langue et
surtout la riche et ancienne culture
Maya